est-ce que l'argent peut être appelé
peut-être avec chat GPT je sais pas si
vous pouvez essayer comment faire pour
devenir riche voilà et puis on vous
donnera quelques explications
en fait très très basiques alors d'abord
évidemment ça dépend de vos revenus
c'est lorsque vous gagnez beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent vous avez pas les
mêmes logiques lorsque vous êtes au SMIC
tout à fait donc ça c'est vraiment la
base maintenant il y a quand même des
d'un peu de méthode si vous voulez faut
quand même avoir un tout petit peu de
méthode faut savoir distinguer les
dépenses qui sont des dépenses fixes qui
sont des dépenses structurelles comme
disent les économistes les loyers le
loyer exactement l'électricité tout ça
alors les courses ça dépend parce que
c'est une dépense en fait qui est qui
peut bouger qui est variable mais par
contre tout ce qui est contractuel tout
ce qui est contractuel en fait en gros
tout ce qui est fixe contractuel qui est
généralement débité par prélèvement
automatique au début du mois ça ça bouge
pas voilà c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir planifier ça par contre le
variable parce que j'ai vécu par plein
de truc très drôle c'est que quand
j'avais des prélèvements avec des petits
prélèvements pas on peut Canal+ qui
était refusé par la banque par exemple
j'avais plus de frais de refus que le
montant
de payer l'abonnement c'est quand même
un truc de fou quand même et ça c'est
une méthode qui existe toujours mais
alors il faut changer d'opérateur tout
simplement alors je peux pas changer de
banque
vous pouvez changer de banque en fait la
fidélité en argent c'est ce qui rapporte
le moins voilà donc en gros
vous pouvez il faut vraiment vraiment
voir ce que font les autres les autres
opérateurs vous avez des conseils vous
dites faut avoir de la méthode ça fait
partie de la méthode c'est la première
étape distinguer le les dépenses fixes
distinguées variable et savoir un tout
petit peu économiser en début de mois
pour l'imprévu un petit accident
aujourd'hui vous parlez de mettre de
côté début du mois début du mois
il faut essayer plutôt début du mois
parce que psychologiquement voilà si
vous êtes tu peux mettre en côté au
début du mois et leur prendre les 15
mois non mais
[Rires]
faut faire attention quand même aux
découvert parce que là on parle voilà
après vous avez des ajouts et cetera il
y a ah bah oui il y a quand même les
banques qui pratiquent que vous avez un
découvert qu'il est pas autorisé je
crois que c'est à 16 ou 17 % oui tout à
fait ça vous faites alors ça typiquement
est-ce que je peux dire non c'est c'est
beaucoup trop il faut me rembourser
si vous voulez c'est pas que tout ce qui
est en a tous vu ça moi j'ai les frais
incidents
ils partent vous avez beaucoup de 30
balles non mais c'est sûr que à ce
moment-là c'est très très clair il faut
ne pas hésiter à changer de banque
changer d'opérateur constamment alors
suivre toujours alors parce que parce
qu'on a tourné on est d'accord vous avez
des vous avez des banques modernes
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle des banques
un peu technologiques des les les
banques tout à fait voilà bon c'est
peut-être un peu mais c'est vraiment des
banques qui vous permettent de lisser
vos dépenses de façon vous vous parlez
de faire alors ça c'est ma femme
peut-être non c'est le planifier qu'un
tableau moi ça me fait Excel ma fin du
foot dans la gueule
elle met tout excellent machin ça faut
le faire faut le faire faut le faire
pour pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
les budgets tout à fait vous avez
non mais le monde de l'argent il est
très comme ça il est très processé comme
disent les experts c'est à dire que là
il faut un tableau Excel mais aussi ma
femme le fait moi j'en ai pas et
effectivement parce que c'est mal c'est
pas dégradant en fait
absolument absolument avec vous
avez un truc qui est très à la mode
aujourd'hui c'est les gens ce qu'on
appelle les enveloppes virtuels alors
j'allais venir qu'est-ce que le virtuel
alors voilà bah vous avez votre tableau
Excel en gros c'est un tableau Excel qui
est connecté à votre système bancaire à
votre banque et donc vous pouvez comme
ça gérer vos dépenses des biches crédits
automatiquement sur une enveloppe
virtuelle uniquement exclusivement pour
les vos dépenses variables variables et
vos économies pour faire face à des
imprévus les écoles qui étaient les deux
du mois comprendra le 15 du mois voilà
d'accord ok alors évitez à
toute ma vie ça évitez les cartes de
crédit
c'est la carte qui a la vérité vous
débiter la carte de crédit alors
carte de crédit les vrais carte de
crédit c'est les cartes
à la début différé et la vraie carte de
crédit qui voulait bien dans la merde ça
croyez-moi c'est la carte où tu dépenses
et tu dis moi je paierai passe-moi aussi
peut-être le mois d'après et au bout
d'un moment voilà on est voilà sauf que
vous avez des taux d'intérêt très élevés
ça peut être jusqu'à 15 16 oui tout à
fait alors c'est en dessous du taux
d'usure c'est interdit et ça reste des
montants qui parce que 10 c'est 15%
c'est pas de l'usure non aujourd'hui
nous sommes tous c'est l'usure
doucement c'est vrai qu'il faut plutôt
utiliser d'ailleurs du liquide de
l'espèce plutôt que des cartes parce que
ça permet de mieux gérer son budget avec
l'espèce vous avez une discipline il y a
des gens qui aiment bien toucher
l'argent il y a des gens qui aiment bien
sentir les choses
non mais alors que le ski l'argent
électronique bon voilà c'est c'est un
truc qui est horrible c'est le matin
alors là tu crois en fait tu penses que
l'oseille il est dans le téléphone
non non mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire attention et que sur certaines
dépenses vaut mieux quand même y aller
doucement et plutôt payer cash c'est
vrai que c'est mieux parce que au moins
on sait ce qu'on aille
mais il y en a de moins en moins la
valeur ouais sauf que je m'arrête pas
c'est une bêtise mais en plus payé
au-delà de 1000 euros
c'est énorme c'est énorme mais oui mais
d'accord c'est vous avez vécu
uniquement de l'espèce non pas du tout
si si
pas du tout
budget
je dois m'emballe d'ailleurs
parce que avoir des livrets ou des
comptes de départ
[Rires]
bon oui bon les taux sont passés c'est
le gouvernement a mis à 3 % et si les
comptes d'épargne qui sont à 6 à plus de
6%, période d'inflation c'est toujours
bon à prendre voilà c'est très liquide
donc si vous avez un imprévu vous pouvez
voilà tu reprends tout de suite c'est
exonéré d'impôts voilà en gros par
contre ce qui est sûr c'est quand vous
regardez les interdits bancaires de la
Banque de France il y a une grande
majorité c'est très clairement lié aux
cartes de crédit
et donc évidemment avec le cash c'est
quand même plus difficile d'être tracé
entre guillemets bah oui faut pas trop
le faire ça reprend de l'argent délivré
etc parce que j'ai une mauvaise
expérience un jour j'ai repris beaucoup
d'argent du livret A et en fait ça vous
créez des taux d'intérêt négatifs donc
c'est vous qui avez de l'argent à la
banque la fin d'année attention
faire attention à l'inflation Vincent et
tout ce confrontés tout à l'heure les
prix de l'alimentaire certains produits
plutôt que d'autres bon ça c'est sûr que
voilà ne pas hésiter à aussi aller dans
du hard discours les coupons les promos
les il y en a qui sont champion du monde
on voit toujours des sujets c'est c'est
sur M6
incroyable
on en parlait accumulé du liquide chez
soi oui parce que le liquide ça rassure
parce que le liquide ça se gère il y a
une certaine discipline aussi parce
qu'on évite entre guillemets de se faire
un peu tracer faire attention aussi à
cette monnaie le tout électronique c'est
aussi une façon de tracer un peu les
dépenses devenir vous appeler vous avez
dépenser 500 euros 1000 euros tiens ça
vient d'où pourquoi etc donc vous êtes
quelque encore plus libre entre
guillemets sous le matelas comme avant
il y avait je sais pas combien de
milliards
275 milliards 75 milliards de liquides
chez les gens qui sont planqués
ils ont bien raison
et les banques qui tentent à plutôt
numériser constamment la largeur
alors encore au gouvernement madame
visiblement un héritage elle parle de
lingot d'or
on dit que l'or ça rassure ou au
contraire c'est en ce moment c'est pas
c'est la grande valeur au sujet ça perd
rarement de valeur vous avez de l'or non
mais là je vais peut-être vous inviter à
dîner finalement
est-ce que si on va dans votre sens
est-ce qu'il est pas préférable parce
que souvent l'argent perd en valeur ça
peut arriver est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
entre guillemets acheter là comme elle
le dit justement de l'or ou des lingots
et de les garder encore en bas en couche
on fait du lingot mais les gens le 15 du
mois ils ont plus rien pour manger déjà
un lingot d'or de 1 kg c'est ça ben non
alors
[Musique]
il y a pas des lingots il y a pas de la
GO du nez hein
il y a des il y a des 2011
pour 90% des Français sont pas très
concernés
ferme le triche chez soi alors oui alors
ça c'est important du matériel bien
évidemment et on peut vendre on peut
vendre ça c'est très important c'est il
y a tout le monde sait que 50% des
vêtements qu'on a sans jamais utilisés
c'est pareil pour l'alimentation donc
l'idée c'est de faire le vide de tout
chez soi et de consommer en gros sobre
et vendre et vendre alors il y a plein
de sites pour ça
bien sûr
ah se faire aider oui alors bon faut
être un peu bienveillant aussi il y a un
banquier il y a des conseillers alors
méfiez-vous quand même des conseillers
globalement les conseillers ne sont pas
les payeurs et il faut être quand même
assez prudent que quand on vous fait
miroiter souvent vous avez gagné
beaucoup d'oseille souvent il y a un
piège
il y a quelques expériences qui peuvent
aussi être positives il y a quelques
voilà surtout méfiez-vous de la
défiscalisation oui c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai ça ça concerne que 10 % aussi des
Français non non non non quoi alors
contrairement à ce que vous pensez et ça
concerne beaucoup de gens qui essaient
de faire des petites économies d'impôts
et des mauvais placements dans des bouts
d'appartements des bouts de Château ils
se sont tous bien comme il faut bien
quoi
voilà toute ma vie alors je vais faire
aider son avis alors être curieux bah
oui c'est la gestion quotidien c'est
c'est une grande curiosité c'est
vraiment faire le tri par produit par
service par abonnement de pas hésiter à
aller voir ailleurs ça c'est vraiment la
base une bonne gestion et surtout voilà
il y a aussi des gens qui peuvent vous
aider à vous désabonner à trouver un
nouvel opérateur il y a des startups qui
font ça
pour changer de magasin ne pas aller
toujours
à la concurrence
pensez à l'heure de la crypto des NFT
pour les jeunes parce que eux ils
placent tout leur argent là-dedans
le plus connu c'est le Bitcoin mais il y
en a plus il y a à l'intérieur
en fait ouais je ne le conseille pas du
tout parce que les crypto vivent une
crise en ce moment c'est un peu long à
expliquer c'est beaucoup trop volatile
et je pense que c'est pas le bon moyen
de de d'avoir un une épargne progressive
jusqu'à voilà sur l'ensemble de temps
quand même
tous les gars du Bitcoin
alors aujourd'hui parce que les
questions qu'on se pose souvent sur ce
plateau c'est aujourd'hui
à partir de combien on peut considérer
qu'on est riche
donc l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur le
PIB fait pas le bonheur ça a été dit
tout à l'heure parce que c'est un grand
débats
ça dépend en fait je sais pas ça dépend
de la région du quartier arrêter la
langue de bois si on me demande à partir
avec quels Roro il n'est pas l'homme de
bois à quelle somme statistiquement
c'est 3000 € statistiques
déjà d'avoir du patrimoine déjà et puis
je sais pas moi 10000 euros par mois là
ouais voilà supérieur
dans un monde idéal vous rêvez demain je
vous dis voilà je vous donne ce que vous
voulez par moi 5000 euros 20000 beaucoup
plus que ça oui mais c'est mon monde
idéal c'est pour moi de la richesse moi
ma théorie c'est qu'en fait une fois
qu'on a tout payé tout ce qui est
vraiment indispensable s'il nous reste
1000 € pour vraiment autre chose pour
nous plaisir pour moi cette riche parce
que
être aisé
quand on dit 3000 euros quand on est à
Paris on a un loyer déjà 4000 euros
la statistique ça vaut rien pour moi oui
on est vraiment riche à partir de 450000
euros
c'est à partir du moment où on ne
calcule plus voilà je peux m'acheter ce
que je veux quand je veux c'est ça sinon
ça veut dire que soit on a un bon
salaire quand on a un bon niveau de vie
mais on n'est pas riche pour moi c'est
quand tu fermes plus voilà on a des on a
des exemples proches ici voilà
alors je vois pas du tout à qui
aujourd'hui
quand on est pas dans la langue de bois
parce qu'évidemment je suis d'accord
avec lui
voilà demain
être riche c'est ne pas ne pas gérer son
budget comme on l'a dit
action on est plutôt quand même bien
aisé quoi voilà c'est moi je dis je
pense que 4000 4000 5000 ça m'a l'air
pas trop mal mais là on est là on est
pas riche
on veut rien dire si on a 10 ans
oui 10 enfants je suis d'accord
sans même regarder ce qu'on veut d'abord
vous allez toucher un bon salaire vous
êtes allés dans un concessionnaire de
luxe pour acheter une voiture que vous
voulez vous avez même pas regardé le
prix
ça c'est typiquement voilà en France on
va pas se mentir c'est totalement tabou
et c'est pour ça que on va dire ouais
3000 balles je vous le dis c'est pas
vrai
3000 euros on est un salaire très
correct c'est bien au-dessus de la
moyenne française oui mais étrich c'est
pas gagné 3000 euros
ce qu'il a dit toute chronique ce soir
franchement
est-ce que vous étiez plus heureux quand
vous étiez hyper riche
je vais finir sur cette note positive
j'étais définitivement beaucoup plus
content j'ai des blagues merci beaucoup